thing about Bill Clinton because he came
in was going to be the globalization
president he really understood
globalization much earlier than many
other politicians certainly the
Republicans you know sort of derided him
for you know they called it global Loney
and they have these annual meetings in
Davos Switzerland and you know they to
them it was just this lot of elite
chatter about issues that they were
really quite condescending to him about
on the Democratic side you had the
union's very concerned about the United
States trading agreements for example
the NAFTA agreement with Canada and
Mexico Clinton was really trying to move
the Democratic Party in a more free
trade direction he was determined at the
Democratic Party embraced globalization
in his view you know it was a
technological revolution you couldn't it
couldn't stop it you had to try to be
part of in the forefront you know you
wanted Silicon Valley to be in the
forefront you wind the United States to
have a leadership role and you want in
the United States to be engaged with the
rest of the world and to take advantage
of of the of the you know sort of a new
borderless world to increase everyone's
well-being and certainly you know in the
second Clinton term you have tremendous
economic growth taking place I think one
of the things that he did very well
which we've lost in this administration
and I would hope we'd get back in the
next administration he elevated the
economic side of foreign policy and made
it co-equal with the national security
side he elevated the role of the
Treasury secretaries Robert Rubin and
then Larry Summers were very power
powerful players in American foreign
policy and it wasn't just that they were
listened to on economic issues they were
players with the Secretary of State
Secretary of Defense National Security
Advisor as you know people who really
had an important role to play in
America's relations with the rest of the
world
and that's been lost this administration
has been so much more traditional
national security oriented and we had
two very weak Treasury secretaries to
start the current Treasury secretary is
stronger but not a figure the way Rubin
and summers were and we really need to
recognize that the united states that a
core part of foreign policy is economic
policy and that treasury you have to
have a strong person in the treasury
department who really is able to
interact as an equal with the National
Security Advisor vice president
secretary of state secretary of defense
to formulate a coherent American foreign
policy that you know can help this
country in this globalizing world the
Clinton mantra was you know you can't
you can't wall yourself off in a
globalizing world you know you have to
find ways to create new kinds of jobs
the jobs that are leaving you know
aren't necessarily going to come back
protectionism doesn't work and so you
have to find new ways to create new
kinds of opportunities and and promote
technological revolution not try to run
away from it
you